so when I was a little girl a book sat
on the coffee table in our living room
just steps from our front door and the
living room is a first impression ours
had white carpet and a curio of my
mother's most treasured collectibles
that room represented the sacrifices of
generations on by who by poverty or by
policy couldn't afford a curio of
collectibles let alone a middle-class
house to put them in that room had to
stay perfect but I would risk messing up
that perfect room every day just to see
that book on the cover aside a woman
named septima Clark she sat in perfect
profile with her face raised to the sky
she had perfect salt-and-pepper cornrows
plaited down the sides of her head and
pride and wisdom just emanated from her
dark skin
setsuna Clark was an activist and an
educator a woman after whom I'd
eventually model my own career but more
than all the words she ever spoke that
single portrait of septum--ah Clark it
defined confidence for me before I ever
even knew the word it may sound simple
but confidence is something that we
underestimate the importance of we treat
it like a nice-to-have
instead of a must-have we place value on
knowledge and resources above what we
deem to be the soft skill of confidence
but by most measures we have more
knowledge and more resources now that in
any other point in history and still
injustice abounds and challenges persist
if knowledge and resources were all that
we needed we wouldn't still be here and
I believe that confidence is one of the
main things missing from the equation
I'm completely obsessed with confidence
it's been the most important journey of
my life a journey that to be honest I'm
still on confidence is the necessary
spark before everything that follows
confidence is the difference between
being inspired and actually getting
started between trying and doing until
it's done
confidence helps us keep going even when
we failed the name of the book on that
coffee table was I dream a world and
today I dream a world where
revolutionary confidence helps bring
about our most ambitious dreams into
reality that's exactly the kind of world
that I wanted to create in my classroom
when I was a teacher like a Willy Wonka
world of pure imagination but make it
scholarly all of my students were black
or brown all of them were growing up in
a low-income circumstance some of them
were immigrants some of them were
disabled but all of them were the very
last people this world invites to be
confident that's why it was so important
that my classroom be a place where my
students could build the muscle of
confidence where they could learn to
face each day with the confidence you
need to redesign the world in the image
of your own dreams after all what are
academic skills without the confidence
to use those skills to go out and change
the world
that was when I should tell you about
two of my students Jamal and Regina now
I changed their names but their stories
remain the same Jamal was brilliant but
unfocused he would squirm in his chair
during independent work and he would
never stay still for more than three or
four minutes students like Jamal can
perplex brand-new teachers because
they're not quite sure how to support
young people like him I took a direct
approach I negotiated with Jamal if he
could give me focused work that he could
do it from anywhere in the classroom
from our classroom rugs from behind my
desk from inside his classroom Locker
which turned out to be his favorite
place Jamal's least favorite subject was
writing and he never wanted to read what
he had written out loud in class but we
were still making progress one day I
decided to host a mock 2008 presidential
election
in my classroom my third graders had to
research and write a stump speech for
their chosen candidate Barack Obama
Hillary Clinton or John McCain the heavy
favorites were obvious but one students
chose John McCain it was Jamal Jamal
finally decided to read something that
he had written out loud in class and
sure enough Jamal stunned all of us with
his brilliance just like Jamal's dad
John McCain was a veteran and just like
Jamal's dad protected him Jamal believed
that John McCain would protect the
entire country
he wasn't my candidate of choice but it
didn't matter because the entire class
erupted into applause a standing ovation
for our brave friend Jamal who finally
showed up as his most confident self for
the first time that year and then there
was Regina Regina was equally as
brilliant but Actives she'd inevitably
finished her work early and then she get
on about the business of distracting
other students walking talking passing
those notes that teachers hate the kids
love you look like you passed a lot of
them despite my high ideals for our
classroom I would too often default to
my baser instincts and I would choose
compliance over confidence Regina was a
glitch in my intended system a good
teacher can correct misbehavior but
still remain a student's champion but on
one day in particular I just plan on
chose control I snapped and my approach
didn't communicate to Regina that she
was being a distraction my approach
communicated to Roisin at Regina that
she herself was a distraction I watched
the light go out from her eyes and that
light sparked joy in our classroom I had
just extinguished it the entire class
became irritable and we didn't recover
for the rest of the day I think about
that day often and I have literally
prayed but I did not do irreparable harm
because as a woman
who used to be a little girl just like
Regina I know that I could have started
the process of killing her confidence
forever a lack of confidence pulls us
down from the bottom and weighs us down
from the top crushing us between a
flurry of cants wants and Impossibles
without confidence we get stuck and when
we get stuck we can't even get started
instead of getting mired and what can
get in our way confidence invites us to
perform a certainty we all operate a
little differently when we're sure we
can win versus if we just hope we will
this can be a helpful check if you don't
have enough confidence it could be
because you need to readjust your goal
if you have too much confidence it could
be because you're not rooted in
something real not everyone lacks
confidence we make it easier in this
society for some people to gain
confidence because they fit our
preferred archetype of leadership we
reward confidence in some people and we
punish confidence in others and all the
while far too many people are walking
around every single day without it for
some of us confidence is a revolutionary
choice and it would be our greatest
shame to see our best ideas go and
realize and our brightest dreams go
unreached all because we lacked the
engine of confidence that's not a risk
I'm willing to take so how do we crack
the code on confidence in my estimation
it takes at least three things
permission community and curiosity
permission bursts confidence community
nurtures it and curiosity affirms it in
education we've got a saying that you
can't be what you can't see when I was a
little girl I couldn't show confidence
until someone showed me my family used
to do everything together including the
mundane things like buying a new car and
every time we did this and watch my
parents put on the exact same
performance
we'd enter the dealership and my dad
would sit while my mom shocked when my
mom found a car that she liked they'd go
in and meet with the dealer and
inevitably
every time the dealer would turn his
attention and his body to my dad
assuming that he controlled the purse
strings and therefore this negotiation
Reverend Parkman they'd say how do we
get you into this car today
my dad would inevitably respond the same
way he'd slowly and silently gestured
toward my mother and then put his hands
right back in his lap it might have been
the complete shock of negotiating
finances with the black woman in the 80s
but whatever it was I watched my mother
work these car dealers over until they
were basically giving the car away for
free
she would never crack a smile she would
never be afraid to walk away I know my
mom just thought she was getting a good
deal on a minivan but what she was
actually doing was giving me permission
to defy expectations and to show up
confidently in my skill no matter who
doubts me confidence needs permission to
exist and community is the safest place
to try confidence on I traveled to Kenya
this year to learn about women's
empowerment among Masai women there I
met a group of young women called team
lioness among Kenya's first all-female
community Ranger groups these eight
brave young women were making history in
just 13 age years and I asked purity the
most verbose young Ranger among them do
you ever get scared I swear to you I
want to tattoo her response all over my
entire body she said of course I do but
I call on my sisters they remind me that
we will be better than these men and
that we will not fail purity is
confidence to chase down lions and catch
poachers it didn't come from her
athletic ability or even just her faith
her confidence was propped up by
sisterhood
my community which she was basically
saying was that if I am ever in doubt I
need you to be there to restore my hope
and to rebuild my certainty in
confidence I can find in community
rather I can find my confidence and your
curiosity can affirm it early in my
career I led a large-scale event that
did not go exactly as planned I'm lying
to you it was terrible and when I
debrief the event with my manager I just
knew that she was going to run down the
list of every mistake I had ever made
probably from birth but instead she
opened with a question what was your
intention I was surprised but relieved
she knew that I was already beating
myself up and that question invited me
to learn from my own mistakes instead of
damage my already fragile confidence
curiosity invites people to be in charge
of their own learning that exchange
it helped me approach my next project
with the expectation of success
permission community curiosity all of
these are the things that we will need
to breed the confidence that will
absolutely need to solve our greatest
challenges and to build the world we
dream a world where inequity is ended
and where justice is real a world where
we can be free on the outside and free
on the inside because we know that none
of us are free until all of us are free
a world that isn't intimidated by
confidence when it shows up as a woman
or in black skin or in anything other
than our preferred archetypes of
leadership a world that knows that that
kind of confidence is exactly the key we
need to unlock the future that we want I
have enough confidence to believe that
that world will indeed come to pass and
that we are the ones to make it so thank
you so much
[Applause]